bonsoir il est 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur tvfils bienvenue
pour le 7 8 ce nouvel session d'une
heure d'information locale nous allons
faire le point voici les titres tout
d'abord les sujets qui sont développés
lors de cette édition du 15 janvier la
situation au Mali le conflit armé qui se
poursuit nous avons recueilli le
témoignage d'Amadou Coulibaly d'origine
malienne membre d'un collectif pour la
défense de sans-papiers en plateau
également dans un instant nous ferons le
point sur les difficultés des
associations Yvelines ou à ski
interviennent sur place le département
des Yvelines placées depuis lundi soir
en vigilance et orange l’alerte neige
aurait été de courte durée les
sallesuses étaient en action ce mardi
matin pour pallier le risque de verglas
également la neige est annoncée à
nouveau ce vendredi et Xavier de chez
est un auteur belge il a écrit 11
l'histoire d'une petite équipe de foot
flamande qui va rencontrer l'AC Milan
jusqu'à vendredi l'auteur est convié
dans les collagers les lycées de
l'agglomération nous l'avons rencontré à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux mon panier local
système de vente de produits
exclusivement locaux de fruits de
légumes de pain ou encore de viande en
avril dernier qui enregistre entre 250
et 500 commandes mensuelles ce sera
l'objet de la chronique environnement du
mardi avec Valérie Auribault et puis
cette information également en fin de
journée Renault qui annonce la
suppression de 7500 postes en France
d'ici 2016 soit à 14 % de ses effectifs
dans l'Hexagone pas de plan de départ
volontaire selon le constructeur qui
mise sur des départs naturels et qui
précise qu'aucune fermeture de sites
met-onvisagé nécessaire sous réserve
d'un accord tout de même avec les
principaux syndicats une séance de
négociation aura lieu le 22 janvier en
accord qui doit être trouvé avant la fin
du mois rappelons que la marque
holosange a connu la plus forte baisse
de ses ventes en 2012 dans l'Hexagone
moins 22,1% la neige qui est donc tombée
cette nuit mais également la pluie
entraînant des plaquettes de verglas le
soleil a fait son retour dans
l'après-midi l'alerte reste tout de même
de mise avec une vigilance toute
particulière pour ce vendredi Catherine
zolato et le 10 moines
quelques flocons en début de matinée ce
mardi mais nous sommes loin des 5
centimètres prévus par Météo France
environ un centimètre de neige est tombé
dans le département les salles sont
pourtant sorties cette nuit jusqu'à
minuit et elles ont repris leur rotation
ce mardi matin
un peu de un peu de glace et là rebelote
la neige qui revient donc obligé de
repartir il y a combien de Salou qui
partent là on en a 9 on en a une qui
tourne actuellement sur Montigny
1200 tonnes de sel sont à la disposition
des équipes à l'entrée de la période
hivernale il en reste aujourd'hui 900
tonnes de quoi faire les équipes sont
mobilisables dans les prochains jours
car la neige pourrait refaire son
apparition en fin de semaine la nuit
prochaine les températures vont bien
descendre on aura notamment demain matin
- 4 à - 6 degrés donc effectivement les
chaussées vont rejeter et les phénomènes
glissants seront prises encore demain
matin et le matin jusqu'en fin de
semaine on descend jusqu'à moins 6
degrés et on a une petite
dégradation pour vendredi avec l'arrivée
d'une perturbation par l'ouest les
températures dans le département sont
inférieures aux valeurs moyennes de
saison elle chute la nuit jusqu'à moins
6 degrés alors qu'elle devrait être
positive et dépasse péniblement les deux
degrés en journée une sensation de froid
accentuée par un vent de Nord nord-est
le redoux est attendu mais pas avant
mardi ou mercredi prochain
le 11 janvier la France lancée une
intervention militaire au Mali en
riposte aux attaques de groupes
islamistes en direction du sud du pays
les groupes islamistes qui occupaient
déjà ces derniers mois le nord Mali se
sont pour l'instant repliés il menace
des représailles de frapper dans
l'Hexagone si la classe politique dans
son ensemble est une anime derrière
cette intervention militaire et l'on
demeure pas moins que la situation sur
place est difficile pour les
associations locales les ONG qui
interviennent en plateau Marie-Laure
Segal bonsoir vous êtes responsable du
Secours populaire d'Élancourt membres du
Secours populaire dans le département
des Yvelines Jacques maréchal bonsoir à
vous président de l'association Eden
association basée sur Élancourt et puis
également sous Mariko malien vous êtes
actuellement en France pour des raisons
professionnelles et puis à bout
artistique Linois bonsoir vous êtes
survenu souvent sur ce plateau nous
parler de votre actualité on va
s'intéresser aussi au Mali puisque c'est
votre pays d'origine votre famille vient
du Mali et vous avez sorti récemment un
clip qui parle de cette situation au
Mali hasard du calendrier c'était avant
même l'intervention
militaire on le verra tout à l'heure on
va commencer par ce travail sur le
terrain des associations Jacques
maréchal et Marie-Laure Segal quels sont
les actions actuellement que vous menez
concrètement sur le terrain
en ce qui concerne le Secours populaire
nous avons un partenariat avec une
association donc qui est basée à Mopti
qui s'appelle remède et qui vient en
aide en appui aux autres associations
nous avions avant un partenariat avec
une association de maire célibataires
pour des activités économiques
génératrices de revenus à savoir donc la
mise en place donc de rôtissoire qui est
là maintenant ne sont plus à l'ordre du
jour on en a mis enfin deux en place et
puis la troisième malheureusement il y a
eu
la situation qu'on connaît plus de
tourisme etc et donc par l'association
intermédiaire remède qui vise à venir en
appui aux autres associations
il y a eu un appel d'urgence qui a été
fait pour justement soutenir les
populations déplacées pour leur proposer
donc des kits aussi bien dans le domaine
scolaire dans le domaine alimentaire et
dans le domaine sanitaire
alors le Secours populaire enfin donc au
Mali depuis si on compte les rôtissoirs
ça doit faire peut-être 6 ans 7 ans
quelque chose comme ça donc on a des
contacts on se connaît les associations
sont fiables nous-mêmes on est allé sur
le terrain beaucoup donc on s'est fait
des vrais amis et donc le Mali nous
tient à cœur et là actuellement on
aimerait il y a déjà eu une première
appel d'urgence pour les populations
déplacées donc pour un montant de 3000
euros et là il va y avoir un nouvel
appel pour justement une deuxième
tranche les populations étant choisies
justement sur place par une commission
pour venir en aide et permettre à ces
populations déplacées d'être mieux
inséré dans la population et je crois
qu'ici on travaille aussi en lien social
parce que ça évite une espèce de de
sentiment d'exclusion ou de mise à part
qui sont bloquées sont freinées alors
justement nous sommes en relation et
alors donc normalement si les banques
amopties marchent de nouveau sont
ouvertes on pourra donc on va dire au
milieu du pays entre cette frontière
entre le Nord et le Sud et les groupes
on espère pouvoir continuer le
partenariat puisque on a quand même des
relations précises avec ces associations
l'association Eden kebabel encore été
créé en 98 de quelle manière vous
intervenez actuellement et comment se
déroule vos interventions aujourd'hui
alors que que le pays est en guerre
aujourd'hui malheureusement célèbre par
les interventions militaires qu'il y a
la lumière inconna c'est pas compliqué
nous amenons la lumière à des gens qui
n'en n'ont pas c'est dans la ville de
c'est 30000 habitants à 70 km
au nord de Mopti sur la rive du Niger et
aujourd'hui complètement sur la ligne
frontière donc depuis 2009 nous avons
installé un certain nombre de foyers
avec des cellules photo qui alimente
deux lampes et une prise parfoisée donc
c'est un équipement progressif cette
année nous devions continuer bien
évidemment et là aujourd'hui on est un
peu au milieu du gué on a nous la
volonté de continuer parce que on estime
que c'est dans les ennuis et dans le
besoin qu'on aide ses amis c'est pas
quand ils sont dans la difficulté enfin
c'est quand le contraire ils sont en la
difficulté qu'on est qu'on doit être
présent et malheureusement un certain
nombre de financeurs se désengagent il
faut il faut le dire mais pas par les
Yvelines noires parce que la casquille
continue à nous aider de la même manière
ainsi que le Conseil général des
Yvelines qui continuent avec nous
l'opération d'agglomération conseil
général qui vous aide mais actuellement
est-ce que les actions sont suspendues
est-ce que vous avez également des
Français des ressources interviennent
pour vous actuellement là-bas depuis
alors nous avons un partenariat parce
qu'il est impossible d'aller sur place
depuis que la zone est en zone rouge la
zone du temps jaune rouge depuis plus
d'un an maintenant donc n'avons pas mis
les pieds sur place depuis un an
alors nous avons la chance d'avoir un
partenaire à Maurepas qui s'appelle
action meptique qui était une grosse ONG
mais tu es une ONG Franco malienne avec
des personnels et des gens des Maliens
qui sont à moptis et qui sont un peu je
dirais notre notre partenaire local pour
intervenir sur eux qui ont les contacts
pour nous sur place
sinon on aurait été obligé d'arrêter
depuis un an déjà et aujourd'hui alors
depuis trois quatre jours contact avec
justement les associations
pour prendre contact avec nos amis qui
sont là-bas les mails n'y a aucune
réponse on a l'impression j'en sais rien
mais que les communications ont été
stoppées avec la zone de Kona en
particulier
vous êtes originaire de quelle région au
Mali
à Bamako depuis très longtemps et donc
je rends au moins je mets une déjà
devant la mémoire de nombreuses victimes
qui a suivi la violence
parce que bon après moi il y a certains
ressortissants qui sont revenus qui
m'ont dit bon à Bamako Mali la situation
est telle que il faut s'attendre quelque
chose de très grand donc mais on
s'entendait pas à une telle violence à
une telle souffrance de la population et
vous arrivez à rentrer en contact ou pas
encore avec eux
par mail et aussi par téléphone donc
j'appelle les amis déjà la région qui
est bombardé qui a attaqué maintenant ou
envahi par les rebelles qu'on appelle le
diabali donc je suis né dans cette
région donc ça me fait beaucoup de peine
que de voir que c'est population s'ouvre
quand nous allons juste faire une petite
pause avant de poursuivre la discussion
autour de ce plateau nous allons écouter
les 5 continents nous sommes allés vous
poser cette question suivez vous le
conflit au Mali prêtez-vous attention
comment vous informez-vous voici vos
réponses
oui
parce que parce que je suis contre tous
intégriste quel qu'il soit quelque soit
la religion je pense que les gens me
voir penser ce qu'ils veulent oui je
suis attentif parce que c'est très
important je pense et pour la sécurité
de l'Union européenne aussi au Mali ah
bah de toute façon c'est bien de
t'empêcher les terroristes d'avancer
toute façon faut toujours qu'on fasse
quelque chose si on fait rien si on
reste depuis la même sabot c'est pas la
peine parce qu'il se passe au Mali oui
je suis attentif oui je regardais ce qui
se passait comprendre pourquoi on
intervient là-bas j'ai vu hier soir que
le Mali était un des le troisième
producteur d'or en Afrique
et donc c'est peut-être une des raisons
et nous aussi on est prêt à aller en
tout cas aider du plus qu'on pourra par
rapport à cette situation quoi vous
chanter en malien également en Valentin
dans un instant vous êtes en contact
avec des gens sur place est-ce que vous
êtes retourné récemment également au
Mali non j'ai pas été récemment je
souhaitais justement y aller moi pour
poursuivre justement mes activités
artistiques mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant c'est un peu difficile bon
pour nous je dirais originaire du Mali
on peut y aller il y a pas de frontière
qui sont bloqués qui nous empêchent
d'aller à Bamako parce que là c'est la
capitale elle est sécurisée il y a
encore des vols qui vont au Mali sans
souci mais c'est vrai que pour d'autres
sorties sans ou d'autres personnes qui
travaillent comme des ONG c'est un peu
plus risqué pour eux de peur justement
de tout ce qui concerne les histoires
d'enlèvement et autres où ils peuvent en
tout cas être victimes plus facilement
donc moi j'espère très prochainement en
tout cas y aller que la situation va se
tasser ou en tout cas ce rétablir pour
pouvoir continuer j'espère en tout cas
le Mali retrouver sa sérénité quoi vous
êtes confiant pour la meilleure
justement parce que la situation m'allié
a toujours été assez compliqué avec des
dictateurs auparavant qui ont été
renversés la démocratie qui a eu du mal
à s'installer depuis les années 60 moi
je suis confiant parce que le Mali et le
peuple malien c'est un peuple qui est
uni et au-delà de tout ça nous au niveau
des religions depuis longtemps on est
musulman et on a pas ses problèmes
justement d'islamistes et autres c'est
quelque chose qui arrive au delà enfin
qui vient de hors de nos frontières
c'est pas quelque chose qui est interne
au Mali donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
nous importe nous et vraiment le Malien
est contre ça mais absolument quoi au
contraire nous on prône la mixité le
partage et le respect de chacune des
religions qui peut être au Mali donc
c'est vraiment pas en tout cas dans les
sens même du Malien donc je pense que en
tout cas c'est ancré en nous le fait de
vouloir rétablir cette situation au plus
vite et après c'est vrai que ça nous
dépasse en tout cas le peuple parce que
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt politique et
c'est là qu'il y a certaines choses qui
nous échappent en tout cas nous mais on
espère que vraiment la situation va se
rétablir au plus vite quoi
j'étais pas seulement au niveau de fait
que les islamistes aient envahi le Mali
ça va ailleurs parce que les islamistes
ils ont trouvé un trop fertile en la en
fait que la population la pulsion
malienne soi-disant et à 90% musulmane
et donc
le fait que la population soit très
pauvre est très islamisée parce que les
politiciens et autres islamistes ils
profitent de la pauvreté de la
population et du fait que la population
soit musulmane à 90% pour véhiculer
certaines idées qui vont qui qui
vont dans le sens des islamistes donc
ils sont d'accord pour que tout le monde
soit musulman que tout le monde pratique
la région musulman alors que il y a
certaines populations dont des chrétiens
qui vivent au Mali dont les gens aussi
des livres penseurs qui y sont et avec
ce conflit là avec l'arrivée des
islamistes ça va aiguiser les tensions
sociales parce que il y aura plus
tolérance il y a par exemple un leader
religieux il peut remplir des salles de
fidèles donc
qui peuvent manipuler ces gens là
pour pouvoir faire ce qu'il doit en
veulent et vous pensez que
l'intervention française militaire par
exemple peut permettre aussi d'inverser
les choses de pacifier la situation non
peut-être chasser les rebelles oui mais
après il y aura un travail à faire voilà
c'est ça le fait que la population va
dans le sens de la pratique islamiste
entre guillemets ça c'est ça me fait
peur parce que ça crée déjà des
divisions entre populations de musulmans
ça c'est très grave pour faire
intervenir les deux représentants en
association qui sont sur le plateau
attaquer en tous les cas pour justement
des chrétiens qu'on connaît assez varer
ou autre et on a très peur des retombées
conflictuels entre différentes religions
et dérèglement de compte et des la
chasse aux sorcières des recherches de
boucs émissaires malheureusement quand
on lit beaucoup de choses sur le Mali on
sait que c'est déjà pratiqué aujourd'hui
on peut s'inquiéter moi je voudrais en
profiter puisque j'ai encore la parole
pour annoncer justement vous qui
souhaitez faire quelque chose pour le
Mali alors voilà je vous invite et
j'invite pas seulement vous mais aussi
tous ceux qui veulent à venir donc le 30
janvier il y a une soirée organisée par
le Secours populaire avec le concours de
Déclic Théâtre et de la mairie de
Trappes pour une soirée d'improvisation
théâtrale avec en première partie et la
projection d'un documentaire qui a lieu
assez barré qui est passé sur Arte
projection gratuite
pour laquelle on a les droits c'est pas
rien d'avoir les droits d'une projection
d'un documentaire produit par Arte et
donc cette soirée sera le mercredi 30
janvier à partir de 19 à 20h et c'est à
la salle de l'auditorium de l'école de
musique et tous les renseignements qui
se sont affichés on imagine peut-être à
vous puisque vous êtes en plus installé
sur le secteur de 50 ans
Jacques maréchal votre regard sur
l'évolution possible et le travail qui
aura à faire aussi après pour les
associations qui vont devoir reprendre
justement vous disiez est-ce que l'armée
française va résoudre la solution
c'est je l'espère quelque chose d'éclair
et de très court nous nous inscrivons
dans la durée et dans les choses
durables c'est ce qu'il faut c'est de
l'éducation c'est du développement c'est
apporter constamment
mission à rester installée mais pour
autant il faudra aider les associations
le constat aujourd'hui si c'est c'est
rebelles etc sont arrivés c'est bien
parce qu'il y avait une carence
d'éducation une carence de développement
et que ça donne un terreau fertile pour
véhiculer toutes ces idées et toutes et
la place est libre il faut la reprendre
cette place et reprendre cette place
c'est investir dans le développement et
pas investir à court terme à en
cherchant des rapports à 10% nous nous
notre action elle est dans la durée il
faut continuer à développer à aider le
Mali à sortir de l'ornière à s'équiper à
s'éduquer et je pense que c'est comme ça
qu'on évitera les guerres c'est pas
autrement on va écouter un autre
témoignage pour poursuivre cette
séquence le témoignage d'un autre malien
versaillé porte-parole d'un collectif de
sans-papiers c'est deux enfants sont
encore au Mali témoignages recueillis
par Anthony Rech
anticiper liberté ce mot Amadou
Coulibaly le prononce quasiment dans
toutes ses phrases quand il parle de la
situation de son pays natal le Mali le
Guyancourtois est soulagé depuis
l'intervention de l'armée française le
10 janvier dernier on est dans un
costume de des gens qui n'ont plus peur
on a plus peur de ces islamistes là qui
nous interdisaient de fumer des bornes
nos bières et de
s'exprimer concrètement comme ça se doit
notre fierté c'est que c'est la France
qui puisse nous libérer là en ce moment
on est on est fier de la France et alors
du coup lors de son dernier séjour à
Bamako pendant les fêtes de fin d'année
le 50 chinois également porte-parole
d'un collectif de son papier de
Versailles a pu voir l'entraînement de
l'armée malienne par les forces
spéciales françaises et l'atmosphère
dans les rues était particulier
c'était un peu étendu quand même parce
que les gens étaient un peu inquiets en
se disant que ce sont les périodes de
fêtes où ces islamistes peuvent taper
donc tout le monde était sur le qui-vive
bon en attendant que soit puise les
dispositions de sécurité
Amadou Coulibaly prend des nouvelles
quotidiennement de ces deux enfants
habitant à Bamako roqya et Gaoussou
avant peut-être de les faire rapatrier
en France
voilà pour ce nouveau témoignage nous
parlons ce soir de la situation au Mali
nous parlons également des interventions
des associations sur place qui sont
rendus difficiles par les interventions
militaires françaises et par la
situation conflictuelles donc dans le
pays merci à tous les quatre d'être
venus on va quitter dans un instant avec
les images du clip d'Abou dont nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure on rappelle
le 30 janvier votre soirée organisé par
Déclic Théâtre notamment ce sera à
Trappes merci Mariko aussi d'être venu
témoigner puis Jacques maréchal pour
l'association Eden à bout un mot sur le
clip qu'on va découvrir donc c'est un
clip que j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
justement lors de mon séjour aux
États-Unis où j'ai été dans le cadre du
développement international donc de mon
art la Free pop et en l'occurrence donc
avec un ami artiste qui est sur place au
nom de viesta on a décidé de faire un
son ensemble justement qui pouvait
apporter une petite pierre en tout cas
tout ce qui se passe par rapport à la
base c'est de donner un petit peu de
force par rapport à notre art à nous en
tout cas qui s'appelle malikanakasi
don't cry Mali donc en fait mon Mali ne
pleure pas tes enfants sont derrière toi
et la liberté va revenir un jour en fait
c'est ce qu'on dit là dans le refrain ce
sera le message d'espoir qui terminera
cette séquence ce clip qui a été pas mal
partagé ces derniers jours sur les
réseaux sociaux et ça devait encore se
poursuivre merci aussi à vous d'être
venu sur le plateau le 7 8 va se
poursuivre juste après cette petite
pause musicale pleine d'espoir nous
parlerons de du travail de l'association
attaque notamment avec ces universités
populaires qui vont se dérouler dans les
prochains jours merci à vous
dans quoi et my peace
je ne suis pas content un bocaux
sur les remparts